in the future we will all have the
option of having our stem cells banked
ahead of time
so that anytime you need new neurons new
muscle cells new skin cells they'd be
generated from the spank I realized that
instead of doing this tedious process of
stem cell Culture by hand
we could use lasers to remove The
Unwanted cells take some blood cells put
it in a cassette add chemicals to those
blood cells to turn them into stem cells
like always the machine identifies The
Unwanted cells and zaps them with a
laser after repeated pruning you end up
with a perfect culture of your stem
cells ready to be banked and used at any
time with this technology we can finally
realize the true potential of stem cells
on-demand functional cures made from
your cells
cures that your body won't reject
cures that truly work for everyone